foreign
it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have a few items that might
help you with a little pampering and
relaxation especially needed after the
busy and often stressful holiday season
all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more Ashley good
morning to your good color choices we
planned it it was meant to be what do we
have here I see Combs I see serums
what's going on here this is so great
this is called better not younger and
this is the first of its kind hair serum
designed for aging hair the deal starts
at 28 up to 50 percent off this is so
cool so you started the route you put
the serum in this little area Okay and
then you use the comb you evenly
distribute it throughout your scalp so
with the scalp that is going to speed
this the source of your hair getting
thicker over time looking healthier over
time if you know you you have thinning
hair go with this one if you have a
Sensitive Scalp go with this one if you
want just overall better hair Health try
this one and what did you say you said
price but I missed it sorry this one's
28 this combo is 42. Right fantastic yes
I feel relaxation just from the glow
right okay let me make it even better
because the you need good lighting and
you need good music for the perfect
atmosphere and that is what you are
getting with Tiki Tunes buy one get one
today which is amazing starting at 19.99
by the way I know you know we haven't
it's early we have to have a little
classical music to get us going but this
is great because you could pair up to
two together you have nine hours of
continuous play water resistant you
could put it on the torch so put them in
your backyard
truly the perfect Vibe for any little
space I've been having these on inside
easy to pair with your phone just like
the perfect Bluetooth and then you don't
have to worry about lighting your actual
tiki torch outside you don't have to
worry about fire and water resistant so
if it rains you're good price again
19.99 or if you want it with the torch
49.99 okay great curls oh thank you so
much which I know from experience are
like impossible to get and I'm guessing
this has something so yes we use the
trademark Beauty Babe waves to do my
hair this morning this is so easy do you
remember crimping iron yes so you just
crimp your hair like a crimping iron it
takes let's pause the classical music
it's getting a little intense there but
I love this device this is 38.99 today
and you will use this all the time I'm
telling you as someone who does waves in
her hair often this cuts the time in
half and it's ceramic it's not going to
damage your hair and it really stays all
day long and are you just straight down
just like this just one two three just
like this and if you take bigger chunks
of hair it's going to be bigger looser
waves if you want more of that I am it's
more crimpy today we did thinner
sections
I can use that in my life I'm not gonna
lie a price again this is 38.99 and if
you want the interchangeable barrels 62.
all tied together somehow I can see the
serum and then you're crimping and you
put the music on and you're good
everything's good that's right actually
thank you thank you appreciate it of
course we partner with all of these
companies to get these deals and to buy
anything you saw today scan the QR code
on your screen or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com